when I was in my early teens I stayed up  all night writing a screenplay and felt  something to this day I swear I cannot  get enough of it was as close to the  feeling of flying as I have ever had you  know what I mean when  when you're trying to get the words on  paper and your three thoughts ahead of  yourself and it's a race to get it all  down before it goes back to where that's  where that stuff originally comes from  and it was called inspiration and I  actually made a movie from that script I  wrote all night and it was called Fire  Light and it was truly an awful movie  but the process was what it was all  about the experience of that obsessive  Focus  of having an idea and actually being  able to photograph it  that's been the magic potion for me ever  since